excellent uh hi everyone i'm omar hey
i'm with vivi here you already know him
uh today we're going to talk about dts
it will be a dtsd dive
bb will start off the presentation today
and then bazaar will join us for the
second part of the presentation and as
always in the
at the end we'll spend some time
answering any questions that you might
have
uh just to answer uh
sorry to give like some quick details if
you are watching us from youtube
at the bottom you can find a link to the
forum
in the forum you can ask any question
that you might have
and as always we'll spend some time
answering each of these questions in
detail
additionally after the session we
normally share additional resources
additional links papers that you can
later use as well
also you can join the discord we have a
channel there if you want to join some
of the discussions that are happening
over there
and finally we have a github repository
in this repository we are
uploading the slides uh collab notebooks
as well we don't have the ones for this
session yet but ta will be uploaded
tonight after
this presentation
but anyways like this is like a
like the
source of truth with the presentations
you can also find the notebooks as i was
mentioning so try to use these resources
and yeah so as i was mentioning before
today we'll talk mainly about dts
next in two weeks from now in the next
session we'll talk about a ict city code
which is a library for a ctc decoding
and this will be a presentation from the
can show team and
they are professionals working in this
area so it will be they are the creators
of this library
so it will be a very interesting
presentation
having said this that's pretty much it
from my side and i let bibi continue the
presentation
perfect
um
let me quickly pull up my screen i hope
it's what's good
yeah that's good
all right um
perfect so first of all happy new year
to you all and um thank you so much for
for tuning in
um
so today we're gonna um like today is
all about like text to speech um so i'm
going to start off with like talking
about like more uh modern methods of
text to speech like more deep learning
based methods of um text speech and like
later on um watson would join us and
like he would be
talking about more like the history of
of text to speech and like how did we
come to where we are and uh you know how
can we sort of leverage our previous
findings to the use cases now um
so without further ado um let's let's
dive in um so we've seen this before as
well uh when it comes to text-to-speech
the key task is to take a text or to
take a snippet of text
and to get some some form of um
some form of an audio out right so um if
it's it's time for lunch then we take
the individual word tokens it's time for
lunch and
then create the corresponding
audio off of it right
sounds pretty simple um and the way we
the way we sort of do this um in in the
whole text-to-speech domain is by uh
splitting this entire task into into two
sub-tasks right so the so the first um
sub-task is that we take the text and
then we generate the corresponding uh
mel spectrogram of off of it right and
then the second task is to take that mel
spectrogram and you know generate the
the audio out of it the one that we hear
right um and and these are two like
individual models right and and we'll
basically look at both of these model
types um
at a sort of high level
um
in the in the next 10 minutes um and so
on
so before we get into like how
text-to-speech systems are or like how
do we predict a male spectrogram and
like how do we go from male spectrogram
to
um an audio let's let's first ask this
question like why um do we think text to
speech is hard you know we have some
text why can't we just
um you know take say word level
word level um audios and you know just
stack them up together to form a
sentence and with that i would i would i
would ask you to sort of um say these
sentences out loud for me right so the
first one is it's no use to ask to use
the telephone
um the second one is do you live near a
zoo with live animals um and the third
one is i prefer uh bass fishing to
playing the bass guitar right
um
you would
um you would see that there are like in
these um within these sentences there
are like certain tokens um for example
in the first one use
which has different
um different pronunciation right like
the way we the way we um say that out
loud is different so it's no use um
to ask the use
um
to ask to use the telephone like both
the use even though the the text itself
is the same
has very different pronunciation right
um similarly for for the second one over
here it's much more prominent um do you
live near the zoo
um with live animals right so
you can see that the first one is live
and the second one is live right even
though like the text is exactly the same
right
um in the second one the first one like
the the first uh pronunciation of the of
the token is bus um and the second one
is base right
um and like
any language is full of such instances
right and um
the pronunciation is very like context
dependent right um and this is just one
of the reasons why text-to-speech is
hard like there are multiple other
reasons like for example um
you know um modeling um questions like
how like the way you the way you ask a
question um so let's take a very simple
question do you live here
right
um
would have a very different way of um
would have a very different
pronunciation like overall like the the
audio would be very different when
compared to just a statement do you live
here or like i live here right so
um
like the the way
we perceive um sound and the way we
generate sound is very different and and
is very context dependent and that's
what makes text speech really hard um
and
we'll also see like a couple of other
reasons why it is hard um but this is
one of the reasons um why we cannot like
why we cannot just have like one audio
per token and then just like stack them
up together and say that this is the
um this is the spoken um sentence right
so it has to be um
it has to be dependent on on on the
neighboring
tokens
um
and
the other reason why why uh
text-to-speech is sort of hard is
um the way texas speed sort of works is
that we we we have like raw text right
so our text can be
um
you know something like um it is time
for lunch
um
and we will go for lunch at um 1300
hours for example
right um you would see that the the way
we write stuff is very different than
the way we we pronounce stuff right when
we write stuff we we use certain
abbreviations for example if i want to
if i'm texting someone then um i will be
you know instead of saying instead of
saying hey what's up i will be like sup
sup
you know question mark um when we're
tweeting we will sometimes remove vowels
from the words just to
meet the meet the overall character
limit and so on and so forth right so
the written text is very different than
the way we speak it right we use like
numbers we use like dollar amounts euro
amounts
um yen amounts what not right um the way
we we speak them out loud is also very
different right there are there are
abbreviations right so every like
um nyc which is new york city um is is
like one sort of abbreviation right then
there are like
um dates dates are pronounced
differently someone would pronounce
dates like um today is fourth of january
right or um so someone will say fourth
of january um someone else might say
it's um it's the fourth day of january
right or um
someone might just say it's fourth right
and like assume that january is implied
um and so on and then we we have like
acronyms acronyms are supposed to be
spelled out um
like
exactly how they are
um for example diy like do it yourself
diy like if you see diy in in a text
then you just say diy right you don't
say you don't just like
you don't say d
which is diy
um so you you basically have to say them
out loud right um and so the way our
text to speed systems work is that we we
we have an explicit text normalization
step first like as soon as we get the
text in we first have a text
normalization step which basically
standardizes all of these like
non-standard words into something that
can be
um that can be easily um
easily be processed by the by the model
and then we can get a corresponding
audio off of it
um let's look at some examples of this
um
so
just the just the token 1750 like 1750
based on um based on context like the
first one the european economy in 1750
right
so in this particular context i am gonna
say one seven five zero as seventeen
fifty because it's an ear right if i was
to say
uh the password is one seven five zero
right so in this particular context i
would i would effectively
spell out each and every individual uh
digit right
um when i'm when i'm talking about
dollars i might say something like 1750
right if i'm if if i'm just telling
someone to pay me that amount or or just
letting someone know about this
particular dollar but if i'm
um
dollar amount but if i'm writing it on a
check or or like if it's something for
like official business then it would be
something like 1750
right and over here you see like this is
just one example like literally one
example of of of the token one seven
five zero
um
being being sort of um
pronounced or like uh being said out
loud differently in different contexts
right so we need to have like some sort
of a text normalization process
um
for our text to speed system so that
like we can so that our model one does
not get confused and until we have like
a standardized way to process um all
forms of similarly occurring
uh patterns right
um the way this is this is done right
now um in the systems is is
in either of the two ways like the first
one is like using rules and regular
expressions so like every time you see a
particular date you use you pass that
you pass the text through a regular
expression and then that date is sort of
expanded to say 4th of january 2022
right
um and and and like similarly like for
example if there is a email id which is
put in um you know blo the rate blah
blah dot com then like you
um find out the date and like you you
the the the ad symbol and you say at
right uh you find dot and then you
replace that with dot and and so on and
so forth so um the first step is like
you know we of course we can we can use
regular expressions there are more like
uh more modern methods which basically
treat
this as a sequence to sequence task as
well so like normalization as a sequence
to sequence task so it will be something
like you pass in
um
say i live at
one two three baker street
um but instead like i just write one two
three baker and then sd dot in instead
of street so then like the sequential
sequence model basically treats this um
as um as
again like a sequential sequence task
but then it takes the
the
unnormalized um
sentence and then like returns the
normalized sentence at the end right um
however again this is not completely um
you know state of the art yet uh it it
it often requires a lot of
post-processing because we only have so
much data and um you know um models
generally tend to make mistakes as well
um typically you would see in like
production settings or at least
typically what i have seen in production
settings is um you know
using like rules and regular expressions
and
um you know statements like those um
to sort of normalize text than sequence
of sequence models however this is this
is an an active area of research in fact
in in the chapter 26 they have mentioned
couple of um really advanced techniques
as well um that can be used in you know
used to
uh replace regular expressions um with
more sort of intelligent
um methods as well
so now that in the in the entire text to
speech part uh now that we have
normalized our text we get to the next
part which is which is you know taking
this normalized text and then predicting
the corresponding male spectrogram off
of it right
um and and and by and large the
architecture that we use for this is is
very similar to what we saw last week
right um with with with asr we use the
same encoder decoder architecture with
the tension right so
uh in this setup the encoder sort of
takes in a sequence of letters right um
and then like sort of processes it and
then like
um it it gives out the hidden
representations um
um
of the letter sequence right and then
the decoder takes this um representation
and um then you know uses the attention
mechanism um
to then further sort of predict um
the spectrogram off of it right so so in
in principle it remains the same like
the task itself remains the same in
in the case of asr we had um
the spectrogram
uh going in like so we had the audio
then audio was converted into
spectrogram and then that spectrogram
was passed to encoder and then like
decoder sort of uh took the encoder um
hidden representation and then we you
know using attention and then like we uh
as an output we get the transcribed text
right over here it's basically the same
except reversed right so now we have
like text as an input and and we get
spectrogram as in um as an output um
and um um
you know let's let's sort of look at
like
one such architecture um like one such
uh architecture type in a bit more
detail
um just just so that we get uh we get a
sense of what actually is happening over
here and like how things actually get
together
um so this is a tacotron 2 model um this
is from google folks um and
it
for for at least a while it was the
state of the art um
and um
it basically um has
um convolutional layers and then like um
in both like encoder and decoder and it
predicts uh mel spectrogram as you can
see over here and then there is another
vocoding process which we'll get to in a
bit
um which creates the final waveforms
right um let's sort of look into this um
in a bit more detail so
like the like the
at the broad level like what's happening
over here is that the
the tacotron 2 encoder um it first like
um takes the text and then like it um
it it creates like character embed
embeddings out of the text and then it
passes them through
um
like stacked convolutional layers
which which essentially understand um
the
the neighboring context of the input
itself
um and then you you pass that through a
bi-directional lstm um and
that particular um sort of
like the output of the final
convolutional layer which is like passed
through the bi-directional lstm um
uh is is then sort of
used by the decoder right and then there
is like a look um there is like a
location sensitive attention
uh involved here which
um
which essentially uses um previous
like like values from previous time
steps um off the input itself
um and and uses those uh and like
provides that information to the decoder
itself um to process further right um
once
um like in in the whole decoder step you
can see that there is like a five
convolutional layer post net um like
this basically takes the takes the input
from encoder and then
um there is also like a two layer prenet
which
um
which essentially does two things right
so so one is that it um it does
something known as a stop token
prediction which is that given given the
given the current sequence so say for
example the sequences
um it's time for lunch so given the its
time for lunch sequence um if we're at
lunch then it basically predicts whether
or not
should we like stop predicting the
spectrogram or not right so it it it
does like a stop token prediction um for
each and every um
um step
and then um parallelly it would also
sort of append the previous spectrogram
like the the previously generated
spectrogram with the current step uh and
then like generate the new spectrogram
and so on and this sort of like
this sort of keeps on happening uh time
and again um through all the steps and
and like through all the all the data
that we feed to it right um
the the data set that essentially goes
through targetron is nothing but um
audio files right like audio files and
like the corresponding text to it right
so
um
so essentially um we can like
if we take for example the most used
english corpus which is lj speech
then you have like a couple of novels
which like someone uh basically dictated
through and then we
um we we basically take sentence by
sentence um
audio files of it and the corresponding
text and that's what that is what is
essentially fed into
uh
the model itself right so
um
like key takeaways from here is that
like you you have like an encoder
decoder architecture and then like you
use previous time steps to predict the
to predict the
the next um sort of spectrogram or to
predict the current spectrogram right so
and and that's how it will also function
um in like production setups as well and
like once we have the spectrogram then
we have the whole coding process which
we'll just get to in the in the next
slides
um i know i i kind of like skimmed over
the entire tarkotron uh architecture in
like uh in like
last two minutes or three minutes which
is not that sufficient um i i i i do
agree but i will send like couple of
links to to like uh slides which which
explain them in detail and like also in
the in the slp book chapter 26 they
explain it um
in
um
in a bit like high level fashion as well
so you can also look into that
um
now so
just a quick just a quick um uh primer
so up until now we did some sort of text
uh normalization on a you know on our
text to make it more
um
um to make it more ready to convert into
audio and then we we had the whole um
text to um
mel spectrogram um
conversion which was done through
docotron and now that we have the
spectrogram we have to sort of convert
this back into the waveform right this
entire process is called coding and
there are like multiple vocoders the one
that we um that was used in um in
tacotron two architecture was
specifically called wavenet and um
like
the way wavenet sort of worked is that
it takes the spectrogram as an input and
then produces sequences of 8-bit
audio
um
and
it essentially has like
i think i have the
one second
sorry about that um
it essentially has like it essentially
uses like these dilated convolutions
like which is that you you take like um
um sort of
piece by piece information you sort of
combine them together through like um
all the hidden layers um and and then
you eventually get um
get to the output um and like it it uses
these to then sort of convert the
spectrogram into uh into audio right and
the output of these dilated convolution
is then like past passed through like a
soft max which makes a 256 way uh
decision because we're converting into
8-bit audio so 8-bit audio means 2 to
the power 8 would only have for like at
an any given
um
at any given point of time there can
only be you know a value between
they can only be 256 sort of values over
there so we pass this through soft max
um like a 256 way
soft max and we get the corresponding
value right
typically you would see that
the audio that we are used to hearing um
is is 16 hertz
there is a 16 hertz model as well uh 16
hertz would essentially mean 65
536 way decision
but the one specifically used uh in
tacotron 2 um
was um in 8bit one
um and yeah um again like this was just
like a brief overview of what wavenet
does
i will send through like more detailed
um slides on uh slides plus
plus resources on
uh both wavenet as well as docker trondo
um now we get to the get to sort of the
the second last slide which is um which
is the overall evaluation so
how do we actually evaluate extra speech
so one of the most go-to ways is through
mean opinions for um scores so which is
that you basically have a lot of
synthesized utterances and then like
um for say for example for 20 25 samples
you create the audio files and then you
create a survey and then you send it
over to you know people
based on how you design your study and
then they give it a
um
give it a rating from one to five right
um on on like how natural does the
synthesized
voice sound right and then you you get
to some sort of a score through that
this is something that is used like for
pretty much all architectures pretty
much like is is kind of like this
industry standard
um
the you can also run like a b test say
for example if you are
um on the alexa team or on the google
assistant team and you want to see which
model performs better uh in in synthesis
um then you can have you know um you you
can have
sort of
utterances or like the synthesized um
sound or like the audio files of both um
both the systems and then you can have
human listeners sort of judge which ones
better and which ones not so this is
also used quite a lot often when it
comes to
you know
testing which model performs uh better
and so on and so forth
um
then
this
this is the last slide before we
dive into some code so there are like
multiple types of uh models so for like
text-to-speech of like text or
spectrogram models there are
attention-based models like the one that
we covered uh which is targetron there
is also like duration based models which
are
which is fast speech which do not depend
um on self retention um
and then there are like for for vocoding
uh which is spectrogram to waveform
there are auto aggressive models like uh
wavenet uh which used prior information
to predict the
brick the next there are flow based
models and there are gan based models
in in my experience gan based models are
like supremely better
um
than uh than at least auto aggressive
ones and um
flow ones but then again it depends from
language language as well
um
okay so that was a lot of
talk let's quickly see how we can
see some of these text-to-speech models
in action
um
so let me
let me quickly um
move to the collab i'm not gonna like
run this through but but i will like
this entire notebook would be available
on the github
repo that we have and so you can
basically just open it as a collab and
um what we do over here is is we use the
dts library from um cocky
ai
and
they have a they have a lot of
pre-trained models already available for
you to try out um and they also have
like really nice fine tuning guide that
you can use to fine-tune the models on
your own data as well so um i really
like their interface um and and the
overall way that you can quickly get to
testing out um different models and
fine-tuning them um
really nice library would recommend um
so we just installed tts and then we
um
then like let's look at what what kind
of models they have so if you if you
look at um their list of models they
have a lot of english models
um they also have french models um
mandarin models um german models
japanese models and so on and they not
only just have like text to spectrogram
models they also have vocoder models so
again for like english
german
and you can see that they they have some
gan based models and they also have um
you know
auto aggressive models as well and so on
and so forth
um
and
yeah so so you can you can essentially
take any model from uh from here and and
essentially mix and match them and and
you know try out on your own
uh data set to see like how how it works
right
so um
let like for for example we can just
quickly test the
the model that was um that we looked at
which was targetron 2. um it takes about
two minutes to set up on on collab
that's why i ran it before so that we
don't have to
um run it right now and don't have to
wait
um
but
it basically loads up the entire model
and then like um passes the text through
it and like saves the
um safety uh saves the audio file within
collab and it sounds something like this
today is a good day
i hope you were able to hear that and i
don't know about you but this this
sounds pretty good to me um just given
that we're just using like a pre-trained
model and it um
it does a pretty fine job a pretty good
job straight out of the box
um
and and with that i would leave an
exercise for you which is um take the
three sentences that we spoke about in
the presentation itself and
you know try your own uh
model try like try different models from
um from the
um from the dts
library itself and see which one
performs the best and which one is able
to
capture all the patterns that we spoke
about right and let us know in the in
the discord chat
um you can also play around with with
different vocoders um sorry this should
be
there should be
but you can also play around with
different book order names um and like
work order models to see like how the
um how the model is uh or like how the
model is performing and like how the
overall sort of combination of texture
spectrogram plus spectrogram to
audio sort of works
um
last but not the least i know i'm about
like a minute over time um you can also
go over to like hugging face hub
of course and
you basically want to be able to
click
on the side and like go on um
in with an audio go on text to speech
and you can see like all the
different uh texas speech models
available over here so this is there is
like from facebook first plus fast
speech 2 model trained on lg speech then
there is the end to end wits model by
espnet team um and so on and so forth so
you can essentially take any of these
let's for example look at the fast page
2 model
and
just typing anything
right now and you can you can
essentially try that out and um in most
cases you can also see like a
code snippet on your left side which
which you can basically just copy and
paste and then be able to run in your
colab or in your own um environments to
be able to um see how it goes
um all right i'm not gonna wait for this
to
load up
or maybe hi my name is adam
okay that did not sound that way my name
is adam but yeah you can you can
basically um try out different models
and and see which one fits your uh
needs better
so all right so with that i will pass it
back over to whatsapp
awesome thanks a lot bb
i
some people were asking which are they
the notebooks later today so you can try
this out directly
and having said that at the end we'll
spend some minutes answering some of the
questions but now i would like to
introduce
eh
hey madsen hey
how's it going can you all hear me yeah
yeah
so we let you er introduce yourself uh
and we will profess ourselves from the
presentation and again thanks a lot for
joining us
no worries uh thank you
uh say hi everyone i'm uh i'm watson i
got into speech in
just a quick intro i got into speech in
2017 i was doing very very pure maths
and one night i i sat down and tried to
generate speech for a blog post that i
was writing and it sounded really bad
and that really annoyed me and i wanted
to fix that problem and i came across
this paper called wavenet
and at that time i didn't know any
machine learning but
the wavenet sample sounded so good that
i wanted to synthesize my blog post in
that in that voice so i ended up
spending
my time almost all of it learning
machine learning and then you know
implementing wavenet and then one thing
led to another and then i ended up at
amazon as a scientist where i helped
build some of this technology that
we mentioned and also spent three years
researching improvements on it
um so yeah a big speech fan happy to
happy to help anyone if there's anything
you want to get in touch with any
questions you have feel free to dm me my
twitter idioms are open and if you have
any feedback i'd love to hear feedback
so
my website is always always open
all right so what were we talking about
today
so i just want to give a quick journey
of like speed synthesis from when it
first started um this presentation is
hugely inspired by the person who got me
into speech his name is andrew green he
was my manager at amazon um and it
really gives a good high level
perspective in
where we're headed and where we're
coming from and i found it very helpful
and i wish i'd seen it earlier so i just
wanted to share that with other people
who are
going on this journey as well um so i
just want to start out with you know
what are we trying to do with speech
research or when we're trying to create
speech there there are five or six
things that we care about um the first
two were sort of like the focus for the
initial part of the part of the research
which is something called naturalness
which is when you synthesize something
how close does it sound to being human
then the second part is intelligibility
which is when you synthesize some speech
can you understand the words that are
being said
so the third part is procedure
expressivity so you have some text but
the text can be said in a sad context or
a happy context so this is about
understanding what the emotion of the
text is and then being able to
synthesize the audio in that emotion
the fourth one is amount of data
required which is you know we used to
take tens of hours of data to create
voices and it's down to
uh 10 or 20 minutes now and with that
comes a lot of research into ethical use
of these models and the final one is
adaptation to situation so as you're
noticing now um there's some things that
i'm stressing and i'm going slower and
there are other things which i'm moving
faster
and how do we get speed synthesis models
to be able to adapt to the situation and
read that situation and that's like the
broad goals that as a community um
we we sort of had been following
um where deep learning fits in is sort
of like making the significant progress
in creating natural synthetic speech but
also enabling better flexibility
so a lot of the speech before deep uh
before the current deep running models
sounded very monotonic and what deep
learning really allowed us to do is get
people to speak in new languages
speaking new emotions and so i just want
to show that that journey
to everyone today
um so i'm just going to start off with
some fun facts this is literally the
first thing that happened in 1928 by
someone called homer dudley um so this
is a recorder which stood for voice
encoder and you might have seen this
words before and this is basically a
physical machine which took what you
were saying split it into its uh
spectrum and then synthesized it back
and this was 1928 so this was not really
a voice synthesizer but then what homer
dudley did at bell labs is replace this
like initial portion that you have where
a human is speaking into something and
replace it by someone who's sitting
there and like moving keys and this
happened in the 1939's
and it was the first like voice
synthesizer that we ever had and
it wasn't exactly texture speed because
you can type in text like you needed a
human to control it but it was the first
time that we actually got
generated speech out um so now i just
wanna show you
where we went from here and also what
this sounded like so i'm gonna play
quite a few few examples so let's start
with the voter which is the thing that i
showed you with the pedals in the
previous photo
um
suppose you sing a song for us will you
yes
well how about all langs
okay
i always love that demo it really makes
me smile because this happened back in
the 1939's and i just love that but
there was literally someone sitting down
and like pressing keys
trying to make that happen and people
had to be trained to actually be able to
use that um i'm gonna play another
example from the voters now will you
have him repeat that in a high voice
breathing sorry
and now in his best face
so i just wanted to show a couple of
examples there the first one sounded
very good and i just wanted to show you
know a different example where it didn't
sound that good so
this happened and but we couldn't really
go from text to speech and the first
time that really happened was 1980s
and what we basically did is we took a
physical understanding of how voice
production works in humans and try to
copy that in in software and hardware
and this is called formant-based tts
system and what it sounds like you might
already be familiar with from stephen
hawking's voice
but i'm just going to give an example of
that
i am the standard male voice perfect
call this is the result of trying to
imitate a female voice by increasing the
pitch reducing the ad size and
lengthening the open quotient
yeah
so it's pretty good to write but i i
think the main thing to notice there is
both of those sound really intelligible
but they don't really sound natural i
think like there's this like feeling
when you hear it that okay it doesn't
sound like a real human and that's
basically the problem that we've been
trying to resolve since the 1980s
um and basically the idea that came in
1990s was along with uh smartphones
coming out and we had to do encoding of
audio for smartphones and people
basically figured out that hey you know
instead of trying to generate sounds
why don't we just pick sounds that
already exist and this is what was
called concatenative and so what people
did is using coding techniques to encode
like small units of audio and then when
they wanted to synthesize something new
they would they would use those
encodings to try and pick
these units stitch them back together
and play something and we got really
really good at it so i'm going to show
you an example
the blue lagoon is a 1980 american
romance and adventure film directed by
randall kleiser
right that sounds intelligible and that
sounds natural
and uh so it's a big jump from where we
were in the 1980s
and then the big jump that came in 2018
with the wavenet antagon papers were
okay we sort of know how to sound
natural but because we're all only
picking speech units from a database we
can't really
do something different like you know
most of the speech units or the corpora
or the databases that we had had really
natural sound like monotonic like calm
sound so you want someone to sound happy
or excited or sad there's just no way of
doing that
and so what wavenet did for the first
time was be able to go back to what we
were trying to do in the 1980s which is
actually generate
um
units of sounds rather than picking them
and it managed to do that in with deep
learning and sorry i'm just going to
play an example of that now
the blue lagoon is a 1980 american
romance and adventure film directed by
randall kleiser
yeah so notice the difference there is
slight but it's there there's a huge
quality
uh improvement but the big thing is
really what it gave us in terms of
flexibility and i'm gonna just dive
further into why that's important and
you know trying to nail that point home
um i'm also just gonna dive into this
like little bits of pieces that happen
at the end from concatenative speeds to
deep learning and how we actually
how we actually got there
um
so this is the point that i was um
stressing
earlier so let's say you have a sentence
and you go to some phonemes like you
have sentence so you split it into
a and
x
so what we initially used to do is okay
we need these phonemes what we're gonna
do is just search for them in our
database concatenate them together and
put out a sentence
and by search i mean literally search
you just like look at all the like
imagine you have like each of these
phonemes you just go through your
database see
whether they match and just take them
out
then we said okay why don't we search in
a smaller way and this is where hidden
market models came in and then neural
networks came in and that was called
hybrid speed synthesis which is
combining neural networks to pick these
units but the problem was always that
you know if you don't have the sound you
can't put it out
if your databases are composed of uh
calm sounding voices you're never gonna
be able to sound excited and this was
like the big block that oh we could
never get over and this won't end-to-end
deep learning uh really fixed foreign so
this last bit of you know picking uh
picking the sounds instead of picking
sounds we're generating sounds now and
again we were trying to do that with 19
set in the 1980s but we just didn't have
the have the tech to do it at that point
um to again just to go into it further
just to summarize very quickly so what
unit selection or hybrid really enabled
for us was this naturalness we could be
very natural but not really flexible
then we had this older technique which
allowed us to be flexible but not really
natural and then this is where we
currently are which is deep generated
models and this is where humans are and
with deep generated models what we're
really seeing is this naturalness and
this flexibility and we're starting to
see that with
things like your tts which was mentioned
on the discord channel where you know
you can say something once in a given
language and get you to speak a new
language you could do things like create
models in or create synthetic voices in
with 10 minutes of data you can do
things like get someone to sound excited
or sad and all these things that we
couldn't really do with unit selection
we can start to do with deep generated
models
there's still a gap and the gap is
really coming from the fact that like we
spent 40 50 years researching these
things
but it was so focused on concatenated
speed synthesis that most of the data
sets that we have
were tailored for concatenative speed
synthesis so that means that they were
all very calm sounding and natural
and
and didn't really have the kind of
expressivity that we're looking for and
so that's why even though we have better
tools we've sort of been going through
this phase of you know getting the right
data so that we can we can use these
machine learning models to the full
extent and utilize the potential that
they really have so we're not really
there yet with the deep generator models
but it's prime it's largely a case of
finding the right architectures and
getting the right data and that's where
the field has been looking to um and
that's where i think we're we're heading
in the future
um
so that's it it was just a really really
good presentation i just wanted to give
a very high level
view of where we've come from where
we're headed and where we are
and uh i hope that was uh that was
useful
um
awesome uh thanks but
i think that was a quite insightful so
thanks for that
right so we have a couple of questions
both in youtube and in the forum
if you're in youtube and you haven't
asked any questions you can go to this
course and we'll spend the next 10 to 15
minutes answering
any questions that you might have about
dds or if you have any specific
questions from batson's presentation
that would also be great
but i think we can dive directly into it
so the first question that was asked in
discord was hey if i want to train a dds
model on my own speech to imitate my
voice
what amount of records do i need to make
for training a model with good quality
um i think i can i can probably take a
stab at that because i was doing some
research uh the other day on that um so
um qai team released your dts yesterday
and uh like what in what an opportune
time to release that and it's um so like
what they have like a collab demo and we
can link that in the response as well
and you can basically just upload one uh
sample of your own voice
and um it it is able to imitate um
the voice um or sort of understand the
way you speak uh by and large and um
you're able to sort of um
convert
um the audio in such a way that it
sounds more like you so um
they have they they have open source
their model so you can also use that um
and it is available in the same
collab notebook that i showed you
earlier as well so you can use the same
model over there as well and they also
have
a really nice demo put up um
on their website which i think gomer is
showing right now
um
as well so um to answer your question
that and you know
at least according to them you can get
reasonable response like reasonable
results with just one
audio sample as well
yeah
sorry i i'll just quickly add to that
like it really depends on what you're
trying to do
so so like i mentioned like you know we
we were in this world of concatenated
speed synthesis for like 30 40 years
which means a lot of our data sets are
very like calm sounding neutral voices
so you know if you want to synthesize
speech that sounds happy i i don't think
you're going to be able to put it one
second of your speech there and get it
there or like you know if you want to be
able to synthesize your podcast you're
not going to be able to do that
uh so it really depends on what you're
looking to looking to do
uh happy to like feel free to
dm me or chat on the discord about this
but like it's a it's a great place to
start but it it's heavily dependent on
what you want to do if you just want
like a neutral voice that kind of sounds
like you
uh this is like a great place to start
and it and it's amazing that they open
sources it's very exciting
awesome thanks a lot
yeah next question is should i use a
fine-tuned storage should i find you in
a pre-trained model or should i just
train one model from scratch
um
yeah i mean i i think we've we've now
reached a reached a place wherein like
um training from scratch unless you have
like a lot of um data available for your
um
for your use case um
then only it is it is recommended but i
mean you should pretty much always start
off with pre-trained models that's what
i would um
um you know personally recommend uh
again um as what's also recommended um
sorry mentioned before uh this
also depends on like what
one which language are you are you
trying to sort of synthesize the speech
in right so for example if it's in in
english we already have a lot of um very
good fine-tuned model you know very good
pre-trained models available for it
right but um if you talk about sort of
more
um obscure languages like um in fact
even just um you know if you talk about
hindi or if you talk about um even for
like german um there are not that that
many
um
uh models available which which you can
find you know as well so um
depends on one depends on what language
you want to um
synthesize in and like second um depends
on
what exactly are you synthesizing as
well but more often than not fine you
know fine-tuning a pre-trained model is
generally the the first place to start
with
cool
let me put one question from youtube
as well so we have a bit more
diversity in the questions is
how do you evaluate most in an
unsupervised way
like an estimated mos
um i don't think
i mean
tts in particular is hard to evaluate
because it's very
subjective right it's not like as easy
compared to
a
audio to text right in that case it's a
bit easier to compare like the ground
truth but when you're generating a
synthetic speech i think it's very
valuable to have humans in the loop that
are able to actually evaluate it
but i don't know maybe there's some work
on this
yeah just just a quick quick thing on
that i mean you can you can also use
something like a moss net um which which
basically
takes the synthesized um speech and like
gives you a more score at the end of the
day um
and you know it it is basically a
predictor of um
uh of mean opinion score um again it it
has its own like caveats um so i'm just
sending this on the private chat um
the link to the paper um so you can you
can definitely use something like that
as a as a starting point uh but again
it's um it has its own demerits um which
is that it is it is only as good as the
moss net itself right uh and like um on
and say for example um if you if the
data on which your mos net is trained on
and if the data on which your uh
text-to-speech system is trained on you
would buy um are different than you
would by default get like a lower
score
which is which is not desirable uh
although like that being said um just a
just a quick rant i i do not like mean
opinion score that much um either
because it's very subjective to you know
people and you would see these like you
know insanely uh amazing papers um and
like architectures out there with just
like one evaluation criteria which is
which is you know mean opinion score
um we do need something something better
but um yeah i i haven't come across um
anything else to be honest
so so one thing that works quite well is
mushroom in case people haven't uh
haven't seen that that usually gives
better results um
in terms of finding out i other than
mossnet it's just something to be aware
of like i it's
you should be clear on what you're
evaluating so as i mentioned you know
there's some goals around like do we
care about naturalness do we care about
intelligibility are you solving are you
solving a task which requires emotions
is the emotion there so most net can't
really you know get all these things for
you so it really depends on what you're
doing
um at the end of the day it's like an uh
what do you call it uh
we we don't have objective criteria for
what makes speech good if we did we'd
probably put that in the last right like
that is that's the holy mecca that's
really what we want to be able to do and
we can't do that so i i think uh if if
what you're trying to do is build a good
speech synthesis model that sounds good
you're gonna have to have humans tested
there's a loss for that the only other
thing that i would mention is something
called the fiche distance which you can
treat your ml spectrogram as images and
you know compare um
compare the loss on that in the
subjective one this is used in the image
synthesis community so that can be
applied uh in speech as well
but
yeah it's uh again something that you
know as weber said this really something
you should do subjectively and moss is
not perfect but it's it's still very
very useful
yeah and just wanted to like quickly uh
point one quick thing out right um so
you can also like tweak your moss survey
based on your criteria so say for
example if you're if you're just
um if you just want to look at the um
whether uh your model understands um you
know certain prosthetic
um like prosodic um
patterns or not right it can be
informational or it can be you know um
sort of question based like whether it
whether when you ask a question or
whether there is a difference in pitch
or not right uh if you just want to like
look at these like really small
fine-grained things as well then you can
just change the way you
you provide information to the to the um
surveyor or like the person who's who's
evaluating it and you can give them like
question answer responses you can give
them prior context post context so on
and so forth for them to um judge it in
a more sort of comprehensive way
but yeah just just want to put that out
um
out there yeah and if you're looking for
a service i i've used amazon turk in the
pars
mechanical turk and that cost like 10
dollars an evaluation around so
if you if you're looking to do that you
could do that i mean i don't know is ten
dollars cheaper than running a deep
learning model multiple times and
getting bad results versus just you know
running
moss for ten dollars uh i'm not sure it
depends on you and what you're doing but
yeah the m trick is awesome
cool cool
yeah and it's like a question is what
architecture oh no sorry so this was
related to the
question about a fine-tuning a
pre-trained model or training one model
from scratch a
albertke was asking what architecture
and instruments should it would be
better to use i don't know if any of you
have any specific suggestions here
i
don't have like a specific specific
suggestion but yeah i mean you can like
i personally for my um stuff right now
i'm just using like the base transformer
text-to-speech model um uh but like it
is it is for a very different use case
uh you can i i would say you can never
go wrong by starting off with say fast
speech um you know fast speech is pretty
good um or
in fact like tacotron as well i haven't
tested out like end-to-end
text-to-speech models like widths so far
so i don't know like how their
performances but um i think
typically you cannot go wrong with
with with something like fast speech
for sure
cool
we have two more questions the first one
is
this one
is english pre-trained model good for
fine tuning on other languages or it's
necessary to find the model trained on
the same language as the targeted one
yeah
maybe i can just quick give a quick
thought on this and um what so feel free
to add add on that i
i i have never sort of used like an
english pre-trained model on on any
other language because intuitively it
never made sense to me um because
different languages have like different
uh different rules right um so i i think
i give an example on discord the other
day that um just the word for example um
25 right so 25 is 20 and five in english
and if you look at it in in in german it
it is 1.016 so it's 5 and 20
um and so on so the the
the way we sort of um
uh talk or or or like just the rules of
the languages change a lot right um
so
i like maybe if if the if the languages
are are like very close you can give it
a shot but um
pretty much always almost always you
should
um either find like a multilingual model
um or just you know
look for a
model which is in the same target
language in itself
yeah i would say i'm not sure what would
work better but i would if if you're
telling me you your option is like
no pre-training and english pre-training
and you want to use it on mandarin i
might still use the english pre-trained
model
and the reason i have for that is so
there are two components right so one is
the text to mult spectrogram which is
the encoder decoder and then you have
the vocoder which is mel spectrogram two
waveform
if you look at the mil spectrogram a
form problem like you know there's
probably things that uh even for an
english recording task that could be
useful for a mandarin encoding house at
the end of the day you're adding phase
back and we've seen things like
universal decoder which you know work
across multiple languages and things
like that so that definitely sounds like
there's some information there
and even with the encoder decoder it
sounds like a big part of the decoder is
going from like latent representations
of of that like text to mel spectrogram
again that sounds like something that
could be useful but probably the encoder
being useful i can't imagine that
because uh you know the text that you
have to convert to latent spaces um is
very different so yeah depends like if
you're very little data and you only
have like an english model and you want
to train on french probably what i would
do is start out with like pre-training
only the first few layers of um
of the encoder and keeping everything
else fixed but uh
the more you can fine-tune the the
better it's it's the usual like
fine-tuning strategies apply but like
cross-lingual fine-tuning does does work
and there's obviously like you know
relationship there's there is
information there that that can be
carried over
to a new language um so it's not worse
than starting from scratch but it's not
as good as having a model in the in the
language you're looking for
awesome thanks a lot
we are already
in time so i think we can close this for
today there are no more questions in the
forum
if there are any remaining questions i
would suggest you to ask them here in
the forum or ask them in discord
ideally in this course we'll be sharing
more resources on this we'll talk a bit
more on this topic so feel free to
propose any topic to this course
if you would
like to see any presentation on a
specific topic for example these
techniques applied for music for example
feel free to propose them either in
discord or creating an issue in
the github repository
i don't know maybe if you would like to
add anything else
yeah i just just want to say that um we
we we typically like sort of correlate
all the responses to all the questions
um by like tomorrow noon so if you have
any more questions feel free to put
those along and we will sort of collate
like one mega answer with all the links
all the responses and like everything so
uh do that and um yeah just want to
double down on what omar said um
you know create an issue on the
repository if in case you want to you
want us to find someone to speak about a
particular topic or if you yourself want
to um speak about
a particular topic in the in the next
coming weeks um we would love to
um help help out either way um for sure
yeah
yeah and
then see you everyone in two weeks for
the
ictc the code presentation thanks a lot
sal and thanks a lot db for the great
presentations and see you everyone in
two weeks from now thanks a lot